[Musik]
grad erwarten wir draußen sind nicht so
vorkommt als draußen zuvor
bald doppelt so nicht zu jung ist man
auf das trio verbessern
tja so ist gut wir wissen ja mit einem
guten morgen keiner der guten morgen
griller der halle robert willkommen beim
panzern hat er dann 35 groß mittel gibt
ist er gespannt ich nehme mal an ist
wieder anstrengender tag
wir haben möglicherweise für mich
wahrscheinlich so anstrengend weil es
für leute das hauptberuflich machen das
mit sich für eine elite gut genug
natürlich zumindest beantworten für
einen tag nach entsprechendem training
dass du heute absolvieren wird jetzt das
wunderbar funktionieren wie mir sicher
das wird spannend
ja ich habe angst was machen die
panzergrenadiere und was macht sie aus
wie banzer keine tiere sind gemeinsam
mit dem kanzleramt das stadtgericht hat
des österreichischen bundesheeres wir
sind in der lage aufgrund unserer
ausrüstung im zoo ganze land unserer
ausbildung rasch flexibel auf jede lager
entwicklung zu reagieren und alle
anforderungen im einsatz war ihm egal
inland oder im ausland ist mir so mobil
sind geschützt und wir verfügen auch
über die notwendige feuerkraft wenn es
sein muss um nur dank ihm zu wissen wenn
alle anderen mittel einfach nicht mehr
geführt
ein job für frauen und für männer frauen
sind uns herzlich willkommen es gibt im
prinzip keinen unterschied
es muss nur jeder soldat und jede
soldatin die bereitschaft mitbringen
mitzuarbeiten sich einzubringen und die
strapazen über sich ergehen zu lassen
die dieser berufen
dieser job es ist ein anstrengender job
das ist ein wunderschöner job und das
ist ein geistig fordernd wurde immer
mehr gäste gefordert werden ich denke
wir haben genug geredet ich darf dich
jetzt übergeben
die hände des offizier stellvertreter
mehrwert der zeitung was es ausmacht
rentiert zu sagen ist sowas von geil ich
begleite dich durch die ausbildung
übrigen dabei video jetzt keiner viel
wissen
ok crowd and ride control cac ordnungs
einsatz wir benutzen das um eine
gewalttätige menschenmenge wo die
umgebung gefährdet ist gar nicht
entstehen lassen beziehungsweise wenn
sie bereits entstanden ist dass wir das
unterbinden
im anschluss wirst du dich bei dieser
gruppe wiederfinden
du bekommst noch eine zusatzausrüstung
die wird heiß werden wir gehen hin
[Musik]
10 anheben mitkommen wo werden die
sperrkette eindrücken schild zu den
füßen trägt prada
so ist es gut kommentar zu übernehmen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ja
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der geht
[Musik]
robert du hast dich bemüht braucht man
nimmt eine ausrüstung mit ok der zelle
wirkt ja ich bin erledigt wir gehen zu
unserer hauptaufgaben
das ist der trainer die jungs zeichnet
aus da kampf aufgesessen sowie
abgesessen
mit vier schützenpanzer ulan 40 man
damit so einen eindruck gewinnst öffnete
hecktüren gedanken
[Musik]
du wirst keine tiere erkennen über
kurses behindert wir geben uns damit die
übung ab zur bildungsarbeit was nicht
irgendwas schauplätze zum einen eine
sperre
zum anderen ein ziviles krankenhaus vor
dem krankenhaus ein gewalttätiger mode
versammelt im krankenhaus befindet sich
also wie das erste team sowie mehrere
patienten verhandlungen sind im gange
schauen aber nicht nur das zusperren
illegale straßensperre sehr gewalttätig
aufgeklärt leichten handfeuerwaffen und
panzerabwehrwaffen auftrag der komponist
die phase 1 öffnen der straßensperre
weiter antreten nach krankenhaus
auflösen des gewalttätigen mobs es
behindert meine ausführungen gibt sogar
fast mehr fragen einfach 12 14h verstand
untersagen
[Musik]
ich zeige für die branche
robert später auch mal geht's weiter zum
gartenhaus was man schon sagen zu
bringen gestanden
[Musik]
[Applaus]
da würde den boden bist in dem fall
natürlich nicht wirklich ein wütender
mob
wobei ich mich gebetet haben respekt
aber am ende sagen kann raten also gibt
es auch shakehands du hast besonders
hinter für möglich dass häufig sehen
natürlich an den fuß mit werden und
denken so viele worte ja echt war das
einmal nur eine übung wir nehmen an so
ein einsatz könnte im ausland
tatsächlich passieren übrigens ja
passiert und immer wieder wenn so etwas
passiert sind österreichische
panzertiere die zum einsatz kommen und
da drinnen zu hoffen in den panzer als
jemand der das netz freundes das ist so
eine ihre erfahrung
das ist echt ein wilder schon sie machen
ihn extrem cool
sie machen ihn professionell sie machen
schnell
robert man sitzt er an abgefeuert
deswegen halb mensch halb tier war
ändert ihr willkommen bei uns
[Musik]